it's been a bit of an unusual night
tonight we we got a lot going on here at
the Chess Club we still got the sinc
fill Cup going on
that's over for you guys but I'm here on
the TV watching ding Lauren and Veselin
Topalov play this this position forever
and ever and ever it may not even be
over by the time you guys watch it
they've been just just playing for
several hours now so most people are
watching that or we have a very special
event tonight that I'd like to talk
about we have former women's world
champion
Alexandra Costa gnocchi she's doing a
Simon you know about ten minutes here so
a lot of people are over there for that
and all I need tonight has been Simon
that's all I need so we're gonna get
this this class going and I thought we
would go over some costing of games cuz
here she is she's literally right next
door to me and you know I found a copy
of her her diary that is diary of a
chess queen you know she made a big
mistake of just leaving her her private
secret diary right in our inventory
shelf so you know somebody could have
accidentally bought this but I thought
we'd go over a couple games from the
2008 Women's World Championship that she
was able to win and I want to show two
games tonight
the first one is from the quarterfinals
it was a 64 player knockout so she made
it all the way to the quarterfinals at
the time of the first game here and I'll
read a little bit of what she says
before this game she wrote in this world
championship not only would I not lose
the game
but I never had to play a tiebreaker all
of my matches finished at the classical
time controls this meant that after each
match I had a free day in which I took
great pleasure in traveling and getting
acquainted with the sights of the Kivar
Dino ball Korea region that she was in
she went hiking on mountains and she had
some food she walked around then she
says in the first game of this
quarter-final against
Ana Lucia Nina having white I attained a
slight advantage
opponents stubborn defense earned her
the draw but in the second game in a
Miss played the opening and the fight
was really over then so during this
event at each round you'd play two games
against the same person one with white
one with black and as stated she never
had she never tied one of those matches
she won them all decisively throughout
the entire event and she never had to
play on the the rest day for all the
people that that uh because she she won
all of her matches decisively okay I
thought we'd go over this game it's
let's go ahead and flip this board so
who Shanina is white Costin hyuk is
black so this is the first game of the
sari the second game of the
quarter-final and Anna who Shanina had
the white pieces and Alexander Costa
nuoc had the black pieces so we'll get
right to the game here and we'll we'll
follow some of her own annotations in
the book we'll skip through a lot of
this and nobody's here so we're going
quick tonight and we're gonna go watch
the final so it was a nimzo-indian the
classical variation and this is a line
that we have covered in chess openings
explained so we'll just get right to it
c5 one of the most aggressive and
sharpest lines so and that's kind of
what she's known for she's known for the
really sharp aggressive style of play
and very uncompromising never afraid to
play you know sharp lines and take risks
and okay this year it really paid off
well for her so okay this is all still
theory and now so the point is black is
gonna put a lot of pressure on c3 she's
gonna follow up with the move Queen a5
in just a second really get a lot of
pressure on c3 and okay and again it's
not really about the opening I just want
to get to one critical position and when
we get there we'll read what she has to
say about it
okay so she says yeah Bishop d3 not the
main line but we're going through this
game very sharp game and so far we're
just we're just gonna get to the the
good parts here okay and in this
position
she said this is actually a game that
she knew between Kasparov in short which
was a match in London 1993 that just
started with this move I guess we're not
gonna go through it so okay we get this
position and we're just gonna get to the
critical part here b6 which is okay she
should have played a move that she's
gonna play in a very short future here
so we're not gonna not gonna tell you
what moves she should have played but uh
why am i analyzing her games yeah yeah
you guys are about to play her so you
better study her games and very modestly
she does not give her next move an ex
clam or anything like that she's like it
just plays itself easy obvious move no
exclamation mark needed but I will test
the class here this is the one part I
want to stop at are you I'm sorry Arjun
you got the answer d4 excellent just
what the idea of ripping open the e-file
and her opponent is never gonna be able
to castle make these people that know
we're doing it to be done in ten minutes
now we're doing it to be done in ten
minutes so that we can go to this I'm oh
so just give me all the answers really
quickly
excellent yeah dd4 just ripping open the
e-file the King's never gonna get to
castle in this game do you guys want to
follow up the attack here you do do you
want to do you have a suggestion no no
tell me just what's the move all right
we're cheating here which we got to get
done in ten minutes let's go okay
excellent move yeah suggested right here
in the front row Knight takes D three
check perfect excellent an after the
Queen took back she decided now it's a
great time to bring the rook to the
e-file and as she said the attack really
does sort of play itself and on a move
like Knight to e2 maybe we got a little
Bishop a6 coming so the King had to move
over to d1 and she actually said
something really interesting about this
next move if I remember right and a lot
of this book is you know it's really
well written there's certain parts that
I really like the way that she phrases
certain descriptions there's a lot of
ways to describe certain moves but here
she says black of course had more than
one way to prosecute her attack but I'll
test the audience what would you guys
play in this position yeah in the back
mr.bad five yeah all right audience is
on fire tonight that bodes well when
they go over there and play her in the
Seibel okay and well we'll play through
the attack removed a very important
defender and again she had more than one
way to play this position but I mean
look in this position to is actually
interesting she could put the Queen on
this diagonal and then just make it
impossible for white to develop the
knight and you know you don't really
want to play Knight f3 because the queen
is coming in so that would have been
slightly more accurate but this also was
crushing you know every every good move
wins here let's see
rook to c2 I mean she's she's already
invading the Kings in a lot of trouble
we're threatening to take the knight no
I guess how would you guys continue here
anybody yeah rook da that's actually
what she played so that's very good
yeah rook d8 and yeah Wow alright that I
mean so many moves okay and now what's
uh what's the crusher what is the
crusher does anybody got it alright hey
Arjun you got to help me out
rook e8 yeah exactly why would a move
and yeah so white was just totally
busted from the opening here the game
ended the obvious and funny point is
that if you take this that'd be a really
funny made just mother didn't buy his
own pieces by her own pieces
so yeah I mean that was just a great
attacking game that's what she's known
for let's go this is go straight to the
next next game here and no don't save it
goodbye
are you playing what's what am i got
what do we got we got we got 11 minutes
so now here's the game after that she
played in me at the finals so she was
playing I guess how he fan again she had
the black pieces in this and the finals
for the championship here was a four
game match and what happened was custom
York won this first game that we're
gonna go over she subsequently drew the
next three games and that's how she went
on to win the woman's world championship
all right so here's her game she's black
again we got a Rui Lopez okay very very
standard opening and we've probably
covered this too I know this looks like
a line we've covered we've covered lots
of real opuses okay a3 the first sort of
strange move but Carlson has played this
on at least two occasions so it can't be
too bad
oK we've the standard development Rui
Lopez stuff here an interesting move
because for consistency normally the
bishop goes to a two but I went to see
to a normal place in the reuleaux PES
although in this position she does
mention this it's already reached at
chigorin variation at the mainline
except white has played the move a3 and
black has gotten to play the move Bishop
to d7 which means this is already a
slightly improved version of the
chigorin so I think she played the
opening very well here a very
controversial decision
d5 white normally likes to keep the
tension for as long as possible and
we're gonna see black really infiltrate
on the dark squares here so this night
it's going to reroute to c5 why it's
going to do it that the Roy Lopez
maneuver g4 not very great in this
position but it can be a very aggressive
attacking plan white is gonna do sort of
the the obvious worry Lopez maneuver
here and okay
age five so black is really hoping to
provoke some dark-squared weaknesses he
really hopes that you you push because
then you okay can just play like night
h7 just to show really quickly what
could have happened so this could have
happened
and now after g6 black is just ready to
play f6
he's ready to play f5 she's ready to
play five if I don't know what's a
normal move if here I mean already we
can play a move like this and okay if
you if you take them and get a lot of
pressure and my bishops gonna go here
I'm gonna try to win your h-bond this
could be a lot of trouble so she just
defend it with the night that I went to
h2 and now an interesting move not
necessarily the best one but she was
hoping to provoke some more weaknesses
on the kingside and okay at home you can
pause if you want to do some planning
how would you guys infiltrate on the
dark squares I'm gonna give it away the
night went back to h7 clearing the way I
can't hit all the arrows at once with
the amount of hands that I have but the
bishops go into g5 she's gonna try to
trade the dark squared Bishop which will
really emphasize the weakness of the
dark squares and I went to g3 okay it's
jumping in probably to f5 okay the
bishop did go to g5 Knight f5 Queen d8 I
guess well pauses for just one moment
did she just blunder upon so this was
not taken in the game can anybody see
why this one I think is a little bit
trickier
we shut that door it's so scary I mean
this is a great class it's the best
class we've ever had they should all be
this short okay I'm gonna give it away
so hopefully you took your time at home
here black has a very powerful move
Queen to b6 so threatening every
discovery ever and the night at the same
time which would just be really good for
black so you can't take it is
untouchable instead perhaps she's
getting off the dark squares now Queen
b6 isn't as great and we will go over
her line here so here and so in the game
how you fan she dropped her knight back
and she says after this retreat blacks
advantage is indisputable white could
have tried to confuse the issue so this
is costing nukes recommendation you
might as well go here and let's see what
could the problem possibly be well we'll
just go over her main line here so you
take and how is this house this night
gonna get into a little bit of trouble
here
well Queen f6 and you can tell it that
Knight is trapped there's nowhere for
the knight to go so it have to think
about sacrificing itself and she would
have got a lot of compensation had she
played this way and after it takes takes
Queen g7 where's our main line here at
Queen g5 and a lot of sub lines but
who's got the time you had a question
um yeah presumably you wouldn't want to
because you're you know you down the
piece because you know you're down a
piece so you don't really want to trade
the Queens instead she gives this is the
main line here everything fine so
returning to the game now after night g3
black truly is a better and from here
she played really phenomenal chess very
accurate obviously that doors open which
is incredibly terrifying okay and so
you're gonna notice how she she's
already got a very nice dark square on
the queenside she's really gonna take
advantage of the dark squares on the
kingside so let's just watch and enjoy
and how how can she increase the
pressure on the dark squares Queen f6 so
really highlighting some of these dark
squares and this exchange will happen at
some point which will will be very good
for black she will completely dominate
the dark squares here alright Knight g5
all right Queen you two very interesting
move rook a g8 perhaps the king will
eventually run away and some lines oh
this sounds on you like that and okay so
real just complete domination of the
dark squares and as they're seen in a
lot of lectures well the tactics are
probably gonna end up favoring black
black has the better pieces
all right everybody go play the cyma
will go for minutes whatever no more
book no we're both this is this is the
book you you guys can get it it's a good
book alright and mistakenly how you fan
traded all of the rooks it's alright
it's just you and me internet so 93
which is a super powerful move what is
the threat now I'm asking you so you can
pause your videos I'm speeding up if
some normal move let's just play here
for example the threat is to take and
then get this big big fork here and now
I got my hand look I got my hands so if
I knew how to do this I could I could do
it alright so after that she took back
and black already has a winning position
so you can't really take the pawn
because then I'm taking on f3 so she
moved the Queen and the pawn goes up the
board again you can't take Knight g3
perhaps some sort of trick at some point
with sacrificing but it's not really
gonna happen
so here's perhaps the best movement of
the game go ahead pause your video Ben
Simon you got like five seconds to
figure it out but do you know the answer
do you want to say the answer
now it's the next it's the next okay
fine
hopefully you guys found it at home the
crushing move here Knight takes f3 okay
so what's what's the point here the
Queen just takes right I mean what what
is really going on here again another
super amazing move here okay if if
you're taking this you know we're taking
the Queen we're it's all to try to make
a queen here so the Queen really can't
take and after this we get some material
here and okay and it's it's only a pawn
like has six bonds White has five so
it's only a pawn but once you see a move
like f5 she's really steam rolling and
these ponds are actually going to be
quite dangerous and as it turns out
these ponds are gonna be a lot faster at
getting down the board and potentially
you know threatening to promote in this
position there'd be a lot faster than
the white pawns over on the Queen side
so that's exactly what happened
we got a position like this she even has
time to move our King up very luxurious
white needs to make a pass pawn but here
comes black let's do a little trade in
this position Queen to g5 threatening f4
White has a very slim hope here in the
book she does say okay there's one
little trick black could fall for here
if you take with the Queen I mean white
gets to promote and wins but okay
obviously she didn't fall for that she
took on g3 and down a piece how you fan
resigned and so she took the first game
and ultimately went on to draw all of
her next three games so I don't know
it's been kind of quick there's a lot of
people in the way but let's just go
let's just gotten a peek from Simon look
what's going on out there cuz what is
really going on out here
still setting up back here you can tell
there's there's a lot of people they're
really about to get going I know it was
a short lecture this week but hopefully
you guys enjoyed it a little bit and
hopefully you learned a little bit about
coasting Hyuk here and yes if you like
this video go ahead and hit like share
subscribe and see you guys next week